yes our star has arrived that's my
assistant Heidi I'm in
see
bumper I was just fixing the toilet
paper so it rolled the right way over
not under right uh you know it I'm not a
literal serial killer I don't believe
and whoa I can barely hear your accent
oh oh no no no I'm American I was an
Army brat and just
just oh Heidi is amazing bumper should
be your assistant too speaking of you
are going to want
this it is very hard to find American
cheese in Germany and you have no idea
how addicted you are to Neon dairy
products until you can't find them and
you are going to want to take uh this
caffeine pill hold please okay thank you
in exactly one minute and 40 seconds to
avoid jet lag I'll set my watch that is
so thoughtful and honestly Perfect combo
I can't take a pill unless I put it in a
slice of cheese like a dog me too what
okay now that you're here I can share my
very exciting plan for you in two months
I'm gonna get you booked on wait for it
determine you today concert whoa
what's German Unity day German uni today
is a huge concert every October
commemorating the fall of the wall it's
like the 4th of July meets the Super
Bowl halftime show except that we are
way cooler about showing nipples here
there's always one spot reserved for the
hottest new artist it's basically a
popularity contest so we will build up
your exposure and get you that spot and
guess what you've already booked your
first show
how do you feel about performing your
mashup at the festival tomorrow
I didn't realize it was happening that
fast I haven't sang by myself in a while
I would not have booked this if you
couldn't do it now why don't we get you
moved into your new accommodations
I just want to thank you so much
both of you
two days ago I was a nobody
and now I'm a celebrity with my own
concerts tomorrow
with I got the car is
in Germany
oh God
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]